[Music]
ahoy michael here to finally cover one
of the zaniest and most beloved animes
to ever sail the great blue that's right
one piece the story of luffy d monkey's
quest to become king of the pirates is
filled with unforgettable characters
incredible adventures and a literal
boatload of laughs
but is there something deeper happening
beneath the chaotic waves specifically
can one piece actually tell us something
about organized society or even how to
rebel against a society that sucks we
think so and we'll explain in this
wisecrack edition on one piece how to
live outside the law and spoilers ahead
for about a fifth of the total run of
one piece but if you like this let us
know and we can make another video in
the future for the uninitiated one piece
is a show about luffy an aspiring pirate
king who rounds up a crew of misfits to
sail the sea in pursuit of the titular
one-piece treasure these aren't your
run-of-the-mill kooks either luffy is a
rubber man meaning he can stretch his
body mr fantastic style a power he
indulges to adorable effect at every
opportunity
his pal zorro is a pirate hunter turned
pirate who wields not one not two but
three swords one is for his mouth
obviously nami reads relatively normal
but she's still a sneaky thief and
kick-ass navigator the chef sanji is a
horned up nicotine fiend who loves fine
dining kicking ass their engineer yusuf
is a pathological liar who has a tough
time distinguishing his fantasies from
reality oh and their doctor is a magical
deer who can talk when we say misfits we
mean it
[Music]
that said maybe a magical deer doctor
wouldn't be on my case about my
cholesterol levels so much and these
aren't the only weirdos in this world in
fact almost every single character is
bizarre and that's largely the point the
farther from the mainland you go the
stranger the adventures become it's
almost like when you're out at sea the
rules of land or the logic of terrain no
longer apply so why does this matter
we can answer with the help of bald icon
leather aficionado and french
philosopher michel foucault let's start
with what foucault thought about terrain
and rhodes in his essay of other spaces
foucault explained that different spaces
in modern society function as a network
that is they exist in relation to one
another he writes that one could
describe via the cluster of relations
that allows them to be defined the sites
of temporary relaxation cafes cinemas
beaches likewise one could describe via
its network of relations the closed or
semi-closed sites of rest the house the
bedroom the bed etc this is to say that
there are places where certain rules
apply you don't run around screaming in
a movie theater and you aren't getting
into bed to do a jazzercise routine
these places have defined functions and
as such have defined rules we see plenty
of the expectations surrounding various
kinds of land-based spaces in one piece
like when luffy is caught breaking the
law
which is sort of his favorite hobby or
when the crew is forced to confront the
reality of farming among other
landlocked jobs and the costs that come
with them however foucault points out
that some spaces are free from these
sorts of rules these he calls
heterotopia and unlike what you might be
thinking heterotopias don't refer to a
buffalo wild wings next to a gap outlet
heterotopias are typically enclosed
spaces
worlds within worlds if you will
fittingly for our purposes he identifies
the boat as a heterotopia par excellence
describing the boat as a floating piece
of space a place without a place that
exists by itself that is closed in on
itself and at the same time is given
over to the infinity of the sea when it
comes to modern transportation the way
we move has become largely codified we
drive cars on government paved roads at
government-enforced speed limits and
take our shoes off for the privilege of
flying across the country in a rattling
tin can with wings but when you traverse
the sea you're a lot more free and
unrestricted sure there are laws but as
anyone who saw captain phillips knows
it's a lot easier to break them a
heterotopia's specific function and
population creates a unique type of
freedom for its inhabitants as scholar
ibrahim marazka explains a heterotopia
enables human agency because it allows
the freedom to create other
rationalities and to follow them think
of how on the going mary the crew can
act like absolute maniacs
[Music]
[Applause]
or how they can derail their quest at
any time to say help reinstall a missing
monarch or bring a dragon colony back to
life as luffy explains he doesn't want
to be pirate king because he wants
people to bow down to him he simply
wants to be free
and life on the going mary enables that
pure state of freedom heck luffy is
completely clueless about and ambivalent
towards money
and his life like his corporeal form is
pretty malleable throughout the cruise
adventures they play a wide variety of
roles and are able to go wherever they
choose sometimes they're saviors
sometimes they're criminals sometimes
they're just trying to enjoy a dinner
uninterrupted by pirate fights and it's
not just that they move around a lot and
make zany friends they also use this
freedom to fight against oppressive
powers that might seek to restrict them
the crew often finds itself in places
run by corrupt governments or taken over
by the marines or even usurped by evil
pirates who not coincidentally have
often given up their seafaring gig for a
life on land fittingly foucault wrote
that in civilizations without boats
dreams dry up espionage replaces
adventure and the police the pirates we
see this literalized repeatedly in one
piece which takes us to places where
pirates have given up the freedom of
heterotopias to impose a very not fun
rule of law obviously this isn't the
only story where a crew of pirates
represent radical freedom but the cool
thing about one piece is how explicit it
is we see a world government that is
corrupt and uses its power to oppress
people and inflict harm on weaker
communities we see our heroes frequently
matched up against these evil systems
and according to scholar julian reid the
freedom afforded to nomadic groups like
pirates puts them in the best possible
position to take on powerful enemies
wisecrack favorites gil de luz and felix
guattari drew an important distinction
between two visions of war
there's war as a state apparatus that
uses violence to control its people
intimidate enemies or be straight up
jerks and then there's the war machine
i.e the eternal human impulse to
struggle sometimes violently for the
sake of differentiation that is a
struggle in which people want to affirm
themselves on their own terms rather
than in relation to some opposing force
it's basically the opposite of what
philosophers call dialectical thought
which always defines two opposites
precisely in their opposition to one
another i.e
hot and cold up and down taco bell and
pepto-bismol as reid explains de la's
thought that when we define war as an
instrument of only the state apparatus
we create limitations because war exists
both inside and outside the domain of
political sovereignty
basically dallas thinks you don't need
to be a nation to wage a war in fact he
uses evidence from ethnography to argue
that nomadic tribes often waged war not
to protect a state but to stop a
centralized state from forming in the
first place
in this view war has been and still can
be a valuable form of resistance against
state control and we recently did a
video arguing that the human impulse for
war isn't really that natural so be sure
and check that out for a different
perspective because of this deluxe sees
the war machine as inherently
antagonistic to the state apparatus
though the state may try its darndest to
appropriate it deluz ultimately believed
that the war machine could be
transformative and offer alternatives to
the state which he thought limited
possibilities
take the opposing ways that states and
nomads navigate space
states organize it determine ownership
of it and place other arbitrary
restrictions on it which is why i'm no
longer welcome at yosemite national park
it's a long story
in contrast nomads live freely without
territorializing the spaces they inhabit
states might define nomads in relation
to themselves but nomads driving the war
machine are striving for a pure
affirmation that differentiates them
from the state we see the nomadic war
machine throughout one piece pretty much
every narrative arc is resolved with a
big fight with the stakes almost always
being the freedom of a character or an
entire community or sometimes just a
cute dragon like the time luffy encode
take on arlong or fight to liberate
alabasta and this is a key way in which
the anarchic nature of the going mary's
crew can teach us about the world they
are violent but their violence maintains
a code and it's nomatic and that it's
often directed against the state they
don't belong to a military structure
that serves the needs and demands of the
sovereign what's more remember how our
friends live in a heterotopia that gives
them the ability to see outside the
rules and norms of organized society as
a result they aren't confined to a
single world view you could call them
psychic nomads that doesn't mean they're
wanderers with telekinesis psychic
nomadism simply means that you pick and
choose from a great big buffet of world
views religious political ethical while
rejecting aspects of those views that
you don't find as tasty for example
luffy embraces the violence and chaos of
the pirate worldview but rejects the
cruelty and selfishness and chopper
views the world through the lens of
magic being a talking therinol while
still abiding by the science of medicine
the result can be as you might guess
somewhat chaotic sometimes the crew has
to save a kingdom and install a rightful
ruler sometimes they have to get rid of
rulers altogether it all depends on the
scenario and on who happens to be on
board the ship rather than fighting one
political ideology with another they're
fighting against ideology altogether and
defending some type of formless freedom
or self-actualization they don't want to
exist in relation to the state they just
want to exist
the key consistency though is that the
crew resists the monopoly over violence
granted to those in power in large part
thanks to their relative egalitarianism
now of course we're not saying that you
should buy a boat and sail around the
florida panhandle to beat up the coast
guard
but if that's your bag who are we to
stop you but you can still take a
valuable lesson from one piece modern
social movements are often under a lot
of pressure to strive for ideological
consistency when they resist state power
in contrast the one-piece crew doesn't
stake a consistent position in their
resistance the way they fight back
doesn't always have to look the same or
uphold the same values rather they use
their flexibility and their position as
residents of a heterotopia to change
themselves to fit the crisis at hand
this mutability as a form of resistance
is very literally displayed in luffy who
can stretch his body in all sorts of
forms as he fights the crew's mobility
both literally and ideologically is its
own form of power and maybe more
importantly for our swashbuckling homies
it's a form of positive freedom that is
a freedom which is more about freedom
for
rather than a freedom from some type of
oppression or control in this way one
piece shows us the value of movement and
flexibility and the unique power of the
pirate and the nomad these lifestyles
that are able to adjust change and
accommodate new circumstances aren't
just excuses to wear cool hats and bling
but are in fact ways to more effectively
think about ourselves as political and
social actors but what do you guys think
does the crew show us the power of the
nomadic war machine should we ditch land
for the pure heterotopic freedom of a
boat let us know in the comments big
thanks to our patrons for all your
support and be sure to check out our
revamped patreon page for loads of
exclusive new content stab that
subscribe button like you're cutting a
steak with your mouth knife and don't
forget to ring that bell and as always
thanks for watching later
[Music]
energy okay sorry that hurt your ears if
you had headphones on